so in your bio it says that you were at
one time mentored by Robert Altman yeah
yes so when I had gone to I got to the
university of southern california USC
for film school in the graduate film
program and and while I was there a lot
most people were doing these short films
and and and they would even when they
were good and most of them were that
good there'd be great reels for the DP
but the director not so much but but
even the good ones people would go to
meetings and people would say well
that's great kid let us know when you've
done a feature they would be like what I
just spent three years on a hundred
thousand dollars of my trust fund on
this thing so um and this is in the
early 90s and and I had you know heard
about Richard Linklater and Robert
Rodriguez making these great little
films down in Texas and I thought well
if those guys can do why can't I you
know do similar things so I found the
loophole at USC where I could make a
feature film which no one else had ever
done before but the caveat was I
couldn't shoot it I couldn't use any
equipment on campus or facilities at all
they're very rigid about that but I had
already written a script that was set in
Nebraska which is where I grew up I grew
up in Omaha so I went back to Nebraska
and and I knew a lot of local actors
they're just for what different reasons
I haven't lived there in a few years but
I said to the local film commission i
said look do you guys have any producers
local producers that I can work with on
this and I said well yeah there's this
guy Dana and he's been working on
commercials but we know he wants to get
into features and I said okay let's good
i'll look him up and they said oh yeah
by the way his grandfather's robert
altman i said well he's hired you know
so you know and had always been a you
know sort of a hero of mine for you know
it's career in for his films that loved
all his films so it was just a great
coincidence and dana i got along great
we still do and he's one of my producers
on my new film between us so um so yeah
and Robert open you know helped us out a
little bit here and there on
on that film on Omaha the movie and you
know and gave us advice to start
slam-dancing after that and yeah it's a
nice way to start your film careers with
a good mentor like that um Harold
brightness also gave me advice on my
first film too he said because he had
graduated from the same university I had
Washington University so I contacted him
and I asked him do you have any advice
for making her first film I said it's a
comedy and he said okay get a piece of
paper I got a piece paper he says get
write this down I'm ready to write this
down he says rule number one I could
rule number one higher Bill Murray okay
rule number two turn on camera well
let's go back to rule number one how do
i get the worry yeah so anyway but he
was very nice and so yeah so it's great
to have like yeah man dan Altman who
would you know say things like you know
ninety percent of of casting is a year
ninety percent of directing is casting
you know and I learned a lot about how
he did sound and the kind of the theory
in the methodology between using you
know individual laughs mics on each
actor and and why he does that and it's
really and in my last two films we've
done exactly that so yeah just really
learned a lot I learned a lot in the you
know from from these guys so what did
you learn about watching him like his
work ethic how he approached actors what
was interesting on the I was on the set
of Kansas City just for a couple of days
when he was shooting that and you know
he doesn't he didn't say very much to
the actors I mean he really and and in
talking to actress that have worked with
him over the years including Sally
Kellerman who's literally right up there
um she was above us using open house and
so it was great working with her and you
know with her background with almond um
yeah he wouldn't tell them that much I
mean he was you know give them the
script if there was a script and many
times it wasn't on his films you know
and then just turn on the camera but you
know casting you know he can't he put
the right people in the right places and
and and got that chemistry in this jail
and
had a great environment on the set where
you know people were just having a great
time a lot of family out of his own
family worked on his films so say yeah a
lot of things like that you know sort of
the subtle things that you you know I
picked up here and there
you